so with the release of Skyfall coming
out I recently bought the bond
collection on blu-ray and I watched
every Bond movie and it gave me a really
good perspective of how bond evolved
over time how it went from more serious
to more campy back to serious again then
can't be again then super serious with
the newer ones and I was able to get a
really good opinion of how the film's
have changed I was like you know what
I'm not a big fan of doing lists because
usually people are very incensed and
angry when their pics aren't in the
exact order and with the 50th
anniversary of bond and the new Skyfall
movie out this is the perfect time for
me to tell you guys my thoughts on my
five favorite Bond films starting off
with number five this is a classic this
is one that everyone likes this is a
film that started bond this is the film
that is heralded as the film that
actually made bond come into his own
Goldfinger with Sean Connery Julie bond
I think it's time was to go thinking I
met Mr Bond yes this is mr. Golding many
people have tried to involve themselves
in my affairs unsuccessfully it's the
film that started all the gadgets had
started the absurd female names but it
wasn't campy though it actually had a
vibe to it where it worked like when
Bond wakes up on the plane and he's
looking at this beautiful woman and she
just goes my name is Pussy Galore
Sean Connery sinks down into a seat and
goes I must be dreaming it was great
because bond admitted the stupidity of
that name and it just it made it work
and it actually wasn't so over-the-top
and weird you actually bought it but
Connery was so good as bond he was the
guy who set the standard as bond he had
a masculinity about him you bought that
he could kick ass you know but he also
had this great humor about him and this
wit to him you know and you really
bought him as bond and he was just a
really entertaining bond in those first
few films later on he started returning
for paychecks and the last couple films
he did weren't that great but the early
Sean Connery films were excellent and
one of the reasons Goldfinger is so good
is because it understood everything that
bond needed to be it had the crazy
villain odd job you know he didn't say a
word but he could cut your head off with
his hat and so you respected that guy it
has some of the best lines in the whole
series you expect me to talk know Mr
Bond I expect you to die great lines
terrific scenes very good action also
for the series it was one of the four
first films where the action actually
started to look like it was actually
real because the first couple Bond
movies well though I enjoy doctor
knowing from Russia With Love some of
the action didn't look as convincing as
it does nowadays I mean this granted it
was in the 60s Goldfinger had realistic
action good Bond girls a fun plot and a
really riveting finale and Goldfinger is
definitely one of the best bonds
you have interfered with my plans too
last time mr. Baumann
coming in at number four in my opinion
is the most underrated Bond movie of all
time
hardly anyone ever talks about this
movie and I think it is one of the best
licensed to kill with Timothy Dalton
Oh license to kill is revoked effective
immediately
Timothy Dalton was the very first dark
bond he was the precursor to Daniel
Craig his first Bond film a Living
Daylights came after what is in my
opinion the worst Bond film a view to a
kill with Roger Moore that was in Roger
Moore played bond at age 57 and
Christopher Walken was the bad guy it
was just basically like Austin Powers
Living Daylights came out Timothy Dalton
portrayed this dark bond he had no
problem shooting at a woman he wanted to
lessen the jokes he wanted to be more
serious and he also performed the most
stunt work out of any of the other
previous bonds at that time Timothy
Dalton had a lot of respect for Yein
Fleming's novels he was often seen
reading them on set and he really wanted
to portray a dark wounded bond because
the bond in the books was like that he
was a cold guy and he was conflicted
because he's an assassin but part of him
wasn't sure if he really wanted to be
that way and Dalton captured that very
well and while I like Living Daylights
licensed to kill was the very first
pg-13 bond it was very dark in this film
he loses his license to kill because he
starts going on this revenge vendetta
against these people who killed one of
his friends and that's the whole movie
he's out on his own you know he's not
going to some big mountain fortress
where there's a guy trying to rule the
world there's this drug guy who hurt one
of his friends and bond wants to find
him it has some of the best action in
the whole series it took the plot very
seriously and a dude's head explodes in
this movie seriously this was the first
dark bond ever and I loved it if you
have not seen license to kill or if you
haven't seen any the Timothy Dalton
bonds I highly suggest them it's a very
good Bond movie
you
coming at number three is basically the
bond that I grew up with it's my
childhood favorite bond it's the one
where I played the video game based off
of it I'm sure you can figure out what
I'm about to say Goldeneye the first
Pierce Brosnan movie and in my opinion
the only really good Pierce Brosnan
movie in fact Goldeneye is one of my
favorite action films
it was directed by Martin Campbell
it was Pierce Brosnan's first outing
Timothy Dalton was actually originally
scheduled to be in this film because his
contract was for three bonds but MGM was
in this big lawsuit thing and once that
finally ended Timothy Dalton didn't want
to play bond anymore Pierce Brosnan came
in and I thought he did a really good
job in this film because under the
surehand of Martin Campbell this is by
far the fastest pace bond at that time
it had the most action it had terrific
direction a really interesting story and
one of the better Bond villains in Sean
Bean or Alec Trevelyan double O six and
I can't help it but every time I watched
this movie I'm thinking about the
Goldeneye 64 lands like going into the
dam and the facility and the game
combined with that movie just makes for
this big nostalgic thing for me but
realistically what Pierce Brosnan Martin
Campbell did for Goldeneye for Bond at
that time that was huge if it wasn't for
Goldeneye we wouldn't be having the
bonds that we have nowadays that
reinvigorated bond because the last time
I mentioned license to kill was a
box-office failure
they'd breathe new life into it it was a
fun action movie it's one of the best
bonds in my opinion
now I'm about to tell you my number to
pick and once I tell you my number to
pick you're gonna know what my number
one pick is because I'm sorry it's
obviously going to be one of the Daniel
Craig movies and I thought about this a
lot over the past few days because I was
a little conflicted about it but I've
come to a firm decision at number two
Skyfall
I loved Skyfall I loved everything about
Skyfall it's one of my favorite films
that came out this year the two
survivors this is washing my toes
everybody needs to all be so what's
yours resurrection
after Quantum of Solace bond needed
something it needed another fresh take
skyfall by far is the freshest look at
bond you ever given because a lot of
fans are disappointed because it's not
bond so to speak there's all these
different things about it they're
complaining about every little random
thing scuffles where the best action
films I've ever seen and it's because it
takes the character seriously it
presents a villain who is not just some
maniacal scheming guy but he actually
has a plan that makes sense the best
villains and movies are the villains
where you understand why they are evil
why they're doing what they're doing
they're people you can actually go you
know what I get why he's like that I see
it I understand why he's like that
that's where Javier Bardem is villain is
so good because you really understand
his position in life he's not just some
crazy guy and Daniel Craig was great in
this movie too because he's getting
older you know he's in his 40s
he's a bond that is starting to lose a
step as ray Fiennes says in the movie
and that really added something to the
movie and humanized bond you know he
wasn't just some perfect spy hunting
killing machine like he was portrayed in
some of the other films he's a human and
he's got problems Skyfall was
emotionally euphoric it looks beautiful
I adored Skyfall it's definitely one of
the best bonds there's nothing I didn't
like about it
I'm sure that you can figure out that my
number one pick is Casino Royale Casino
Royale did for bond what no other Bond
film has ever done for bond and it's
interesting because that's directed by
Martin Campbell as well who made
Goldeneye that guy has successfully
launched two bonds without martin
campbell bond wouldn't be what it is
nowadays that guy really understands
bond and Casino Royale was just like
injected into my veins when I saw like I
don't even know it was like a drug or
something like it was just in me I was
like oh my god this is a great movie I
hope I'll live game is I'm causing you
to perspire it doesn't bother you
killing those people well I wouldn't be
very good at my job but it did and it
wasn't just because the action was so
amazing it was because it presented a
human bond cuz I just watched the whole
series and I can see how constantly the
series starts serious then gets to this
height of camp and then another guy
comes in is like look okay we're gonna
make it serious again the same thing
happened with Pierce Brosnan died
another day on a surfboard holding
parachutes and this giant laser beam and
everything and it was just it was really
it just went over the top Casino Royale
came and it went look Bond is more than
this bond can be Ryo bond can be serious
it can be hardcore it can be badass and
we can actually portray a bond you
actually think yeah I wouldn't cross
that guy because he would kill me like
you you just really feel that in this
movie and Martin Campbell made this
movie so visceral and so entertaining
but it's not just that it also has a
great Bond villain in leshiy f-- because
once again I'm going to reiterate the
best villains are the people that you
understand you understand exactly
Wireless chief needs all this money his
life is on the line in this movie
because you can see him constantly
trying to get his hands on money and
you're like this guy just wants money
but as the film progresses you realize
this guy teens money or he's going to be
killed and you really understand him as
a villain and the poker scenes I've
never seen more riveting card games I
mean it was just so great to realize
that basically 30 40 minutes of this
movie pass and there is one fight scene
in a stairwell but it's mostly card
games and him getting to know Vesper the
best Bond girl in my opinion ever and
it's riveting the film looks amazing
it's film beautifully the dialogue is
great it had
everything that the other Bond films I
thought needed and more so any problems
I had with other bonds were answer in
this film it's one of my all-time
favorite films it really is and as I
said the Bond girl in this movie was so
special because he was the first goal to
really reach his heart and there's so
many things under the surface of Casino
Royale that were so impressive like for
instance you never actually hear the
James Bond theme until the end of the
film because he's not James Bond as we
know until the end of the film because
Vesper hurt him made him cold towards
women and now you understand why James
Bond is James Bond it was like Batman
Begins for James Bond
so those are my picks for my five
favorite Bond films if you guys have
different opinions I understand because
every time I ever present a list there's
always something that's fine an opinion
in his opinion and it's it's a movie for
goodness sakes you know what's your
opinion what Bond films do you like
thanks a lot for watching guys and as
always if you like this then you can
click right here and get stuck my knives